the main stories but witches true what
they say I'm one of these fans I am I am
one of them 100% rabidly enthusiastic
about doing the right thing for the show
big fan of the games a huge fan of the
books as well and so for me I am I'm in
the same boat as them like no prisoners
yes and I'll be on my way there is a lot
of complexity go out and you see a lot
of that in the books some of that
doesn't necessarily translate to the
show because due to the nature of their
being fantastic storylines which are
existing alongside Geralt had to boil
down to the very essence of who he was
and for me that was a hard line stony
exterior individual who we get to see
him come out of every now and again
depend on who is interacting with but in
the books we see someone who's a bit
more because the ability to or will
openly converse with kings and queens in
their language and then when he's bored
of their don't know how much I can swear
on this rubbish then he'll be more
hardline and you'll see that transition
I don't think I saw you smile once
really who isn't weird to just keep so
stone-faced all the time it's all
depending on on how how the editing room
lays out it's it's all it's all based
upon story certainly the character does
smile there are smiles in there but it
depends on on on what we want to show
the most well you finally get to talk
about it I mean you I think you've had
to be pretty secretive was that
difficult and how much pressure did you
feel from this rabid fandom that loves
this story so much I didn't feel any
pressure at all I mean and if I did it's
coming from myself I'm one of these fans
I am I am one of them 100% rabidly
enthusiastic about doing the right thing
for this show and I've been a fan of the
fantasy genre since I was a boy and big
fan of the games a huge fan of the books
as well and so for me I am I'm in the
same boat as they're like no prisoners I
do think it is impossible in today's day
and age to make an amazing fantasy show
like this and not get those Game of
Thrones
comparison right what do you have to say
to people who are making the comparisons
what's your thought on it I think
comparisons are always gonna be made and
it is it's fun it's fine with their two
ends of the spectrum in a fantasy genre
but that's like saying someone's gonna
be the next Tom Cruise no one's gonna be
the next Tom Cruise
you fought Tom Cruise yes I bought him
yeah but even even I who fought him
isn't gonna be the next Tom Cruise Tom
Cruise is Tom Cruise and he exists as
Tom Cruise whatever happens next
Tom Cruise is Game of Thrones whatever
happens next The Witcher is never gonna
be Game of Thrones it's gonna be
something else completely different and
it exists within that fantasy genre yes
but it must exist by itself otherwise
they'll always be there yeah but Tom
Cruise did this and you didn't do that
it's always gonna be as a pointment
nobody can run as fast as Tom Cruise no
one can run as fast or as long or in as
many movies not a hard choice the
physical transformation what did you
think when you first looked in the
mirror and saw yourself with that hair
it's the hair went through an evolution
and I it really did I was on quite close
to the beginning of shooting there's
only so much time I had to bring my team
on and then my team got to work on on
things like the Wigan and we we put a
lot of a lot of hard work into the
research of it Jacki Rathore
who's my hairdresser she was working on
my wig every single night add multiple
wigs and some were somewhat better than
others for fighting some were used for
all the water work whatever it may be
and huge amounts of work went into it
where we landed with makeup and wig and
costume by the end of it was was
absolutely perfect and I was so
impressed with the work that everyone
put in because we were working long
hours anyway and then they went home and
they took that wig with them I'm sure
she has various names so did you I mean
white hair it's ya know it's a it helped
transform the character me into the
character I love that bit you do so much
physically what was training for this
like versus training for what sort of
the ultimate superhero super method
right they are the same but different
the biggest similarity and the most
taxing thing is always going to be time
this is about getting that training in
each day and forcing yourself to do it
you've finished a very long shift and
you were there two hours early two and a
half hours early for you your hair and
your makeup and then you have to go to
the gym and it's probably a busy gym and
so I was very lucky in in Budapest to
work it at Flex gym and it's one of the
best gyms I've been to one of the best
public gyms I've been to I love this
shout out they're getting right now oh
no did they deserve it they deserve it
and they looked after me so well there
people are wanting to talk to you cuz
you're Superman
I was no no not that at all no initially
I thought that I thought this is you
know it is what it is but absolutely not
they just helped me they helped me get
through my training process at the end
of each day so I could get home as soon
as possible and and then get to bed and
then wash and repeat the next day well I
gotta ask you you did say with the Man
of Steel what do you want your continued
journey with Superman to be I'd like to
delve more into the the aspect of
Superman who we traditionally know
coupled with where we left him at the
end of Man of Steel it's the hero who is
trying to exist in a world where people
may say he's not relevant anymore
where actually he's extraordinarily
relevant and it's him coming to terms
with that and becoming that relevance
and showing people that hope does exist
without a being - chocolate box I wanted
to still have an edge but but to have
some warmth to it and to have some hope
to it last question for you for fans of
the books the gamers are there Easter
eggs in Witcher will they see some some
nods and some things you put in there
yes yes they will if they're watching
carefully tease it I give no no no no
that's that ruins the whole point okay
just just just keep your eyes peeled
[Music]